hey there and thanks for stopping by my
name is bradley knapp and i'm one of the
product managers here at ibm cloud
and the question that we're going to
answer today is what is the difference
between devops and sre this is a
question that i hear on a fairly regular
basis
not just internally but from external
customers as well and it's one that we'd
like to help you
walk through so that you can really
figure out what makes sense in your
organization and
i think the answer is probably going to
surprise you a little bit
before we get into the video that i do
want to encourage you to like and
subscribe if you think that you're going
to enjoy these things
just click on those buttons that way you
get notified every time we come out with
something new
so with that let's get right into the
question and the question
is devops
versus sre
and so as we get into this i think
probably the most important thing to
understand
is this isn't a versus question you
don't have to have
one or the other as a matter of fact i
would argue and i think that many people
would agree
that sre is actually an essential
component
of devops and devops a good properly
implemented devops method
leads to the necessity of sre when it
comes time to deploy
there are two sides of the same coin and
so that's obviously going to lead to a
little bit of confusion because
devops is the development methodology
right that's it's all about
integrating your development teams and
your operations teams it's about
knocking down those silos between them
it's about ensuring that everybody is
singing off the same
song book and that's very important and
sre
is in charge of automating all of the
things and making sure that you never go
down
there are really two parts of the same
group and so
let's look at the differences right
because they do have some differences
probably the first and largest one is
that when we think about our devops site
over here right
devops is about core development
the devops guys particularly your
developers
they are doing the core development they
are answering the question
what do we want to do they are working
with product they're working with sales
they're working with marketing
to develop design and deploy what is it
that we do
they're working on the core sre on the
other hand
they're not working on the core what
they are working is the implementation
of the core they are working on the
deployment
and they are constantly giving feedback
back into that core development group to
say hey
something that you guys have designed
isn't working exactly the way that you
think that it is
so if we were to break that down a
little bit more they are
helping the devops group our sre group
is helping the devops group
to break down even more of those silos
if you
want to think about it this way devops
is trying to develop the answer to
how do we solve this problem sre is
saying
how do we deploy and maintain and run
to solve this problem it's the
theoretical
versus the practical and ideally
they're talking to each other every day
right because sre
should be logging defects they should be
logging tickets back with development
but probably most importantly they need
to understand that they have the same
goals these groups should
never be aligned against one another
and so they do have to have a common
understanding let's talk about one of
the most important parts right
we're going to talk about failure
because failure is not necessary
failure is just a way of life it doesn't
matter what you deploy it doesn't matter
how well it goes
it's going to happen and so when we talk
about failure
everyone involved needs to understand
that there's going to be some level
right there is a
failure budget or an error budget where
things are going to go wrong
and what happens when things go wrong
that's what figures out whether or not
your organization is working
because your sre team when it comes to
failure
they're going to anticipate it they're
going to monitor it they're going to log
it they're going to record
everything and ideally they can identify
a failure
before it happens they're going to have
predictive analytics that are going to
say all right this thing is going to go
bad
based on what we've seen before and so
sre is responsible for mitigating some
of those failures
through monitoring and logging and doing
the preemptive parts
right so we'll do the monitors we'll do
the logs
sre is also going to lead all of your
post actual failure incident management
right they're going to get you through
the incident to begin with
and then they're going to hot wash it
when it's done they're going to lead
that rca that root cause analysis and
after they have that rca completed
and this is the most important part they
have to take that rca data
and bring it back over into dev and get
some tickets open
you have to get dev online because
you've gotta
these are the guys who are gonna solve
the core problem some rcas might be
solved by sre internally right they're
gonna spend 50 percent of their time
writing 50
of their time working and so some of
that problem they may be able to fix
directly
but sometimes that's not the case right
our rca may have found
a problem that only dev can fix and
that's all right that's not a big
deal they're going to get that over here
dev is going to implement
and then probably the most important
part right so you're going to get that
new feature
dev is going to get that pulled together
they're going to get that new feature
rolled out
and then they're going to pass that back
into sre and they're going to say hey
sre that problem that we had we got a
new feature for you
and then our guys on the sre side what
do they do they then have to take that
feature
and they have to figure out how to
integrate it into their monitoring and
their logging efforts
to make sure that we don't get into
another rca for the same kind of a
problem
so these groups they are part and parcel
of the same bunch you really can't have
one successful organization without
another
and when it comes to figuring out a
distinction
it's not something that you should spend
a lot of time with there are different
skill sets right
core development devops these are the
guys that really love writing software
sre is a little bit more of an
investigative mindset right you have to
be willing to go and do that analysis
figure out what things have gone wrong
automate all of the things but there's a
lot that they have in common
everyone should be writing automation
everyone should be getting rid of toil
as much as possible
because we just don't have the time to
be doing manual tasks
when we can put the computers in charge
of it right
computers are not great at thinking on
their own but if you need it to do the
same thing
over and over and over again in exactly
the same way
you can't beat computing for that and so
automation is key
you just have a slightly different
mindset devops is going to automate
deployment they're going to automate
tasks they're going to automate feature
sre is going to automate redundancy and
they're going to automate
manual tasks that they can turn into
programmatic tasks
to keep the stack up and so
you know when we talk about devops
versus sre that's not the question
the question is how do we build devops
how do we build sre
and how do we be sure that they are
always talking to each other because the
institutional knowledge that sre has so
much of
if that doesn't get passed back into
your devops group you're never going to
be successful
you're going to have a silo here and a
silo here and at the end of the day
both of these philosophies core core
component
is getting rid of silos freeing
ourselves from those silos
is what is going to make us all more
successful
thank you so much for stopping by the
channel today if you have any questions
or comments please feel free to share
them with us below
if you enjoyed this video and you would
like to see more like it in the future
please do like the video and subscribe
to us so that we'll know to keep
creating for you